the time for talking is over it's time  to push bunnies you're flying eggs are  pretty impressive mr. Eggman but let's  face it you'll never catch me hon  fidence a fool's substitute for  intelligence that's not good  Sonic and then you got the SuperSpeed  and everything but Maddie and I totally  defense this probably gonna get blown up  pretty much yeah don't worry I know  exactly what to do I was not expecting  that but I was expecting not to expect  something so it doesn't count  oh this one is cute let's keep  Dora will be so terrible  you've got car insurance right buzz off  that doesn't sound good  no peeking is bad get rid of it I'm  trying roll it up the winter coat  anywhere I can't get it alright I'm  pulling over  did I get it nope hold still it's going  it's still here  [Music]  you